oh my god Alexa that was terrifying we
just got to see flock and I have heard
nothing about it you wanted me to see
this game now I'm freaked out where did
you find this game so I was actually at
Gamescom in 2013 and I walked by the
Nordic booth and there were a bunch of
small student projects and there was
this one group of five guys and they
were showing this creepy game with these
creepy creatures running around with
lights and I walked up and I said what
are you guys playing and they SAT me
down and it was the flock and it's alpha
and its first iteration and even then it
was creepy I was creeped out I was
jumping it was very very like it made me
very nervous and I loved it because it
was sort of like a survival horror red
light green light game and now they're
here at GDC two years later and it's
iterated so much and what that initial
prototype was and it's scarier you were
a hundred percent correct I you told me
you hyped it up a little bit I didn't
know what to expect it is terrifying it
actually really invoke sphere this is a
five up to five players multiplayer game
where you're basically you're basically
all monsters at first is that right yeah
you're a creepy skeleton with like
monster claw hands like you're deform
punch fact I think when they explain the
story to me you're like the last
remnants of humanity and you're all
deformed and gross that's tearing it's
great I know it's all right
and you're you essentially have like
there's an artifact when I first played
it it was just a simple mirror but the
artifact is like this little piece of
technology that it's like a flashlight
it's like a really cool-looking
flashlight and you have to run around
with it and if you shine it on another
monster they burn up and they die and
that's how you get them out and they're
always coming after you they're always
trying to trying to knock you out
they'll they can like shoot across long
distances and take you down and they can
also make decoys which wasn't in the
first build which I love in this one you
can literally make a copy of yourself
and walk away from it and if you ever
want to reclaim that copy like let's say
the person carrying the artifact walks
by your copy you can hit one button and
suddenly inhabit your copy and then
reach out and grab them like you can be
watching them from multiple angles it's
like really really cool you know we were
watching the game play and giving our
hands on it it was amazing how much when
you're winning is when you have that
artifact you're actually gaining points
right and the person with the most
points or when you accumulate enough
points you win yeah you capture like
there's bases you can capture like I
think it's like if you get three you win
the level right and this is one of these
games that the more you're winning the
scarier it gets because people are
constantly coming after you more and
you're incredibly paranoid so you might
see someone over the rafters jumping
over a building and a on the corner of
your eye and you run to your right and
go oh my god there's someone right there
but you won't even realize there might
be a decoy anywhere around you waiting
to kill you're never safe the best part
I think the best piece of are the best
mechanic I think is you you can't stop
moving if you stop moving your
flashlight battery dies and you have to
keep running to recharge it so you have
to
moving if you have the flashlight if you
don't have it and you stand still you
turn into a statue of yourself and
there's a bunch of the creepy humanoid
statues scattered throughout the levels
but you turn into a statue and you it
limits your field of vision so you can't
see a lot so the game encourages you to
keep moving no matter what one of the
most amazing things that I thought about
this game that I thought was just
incredibly well done where the sound
effects sounds will haunt you oh yeah
they are I don't I don't remember what
they were like in the first field but in
this one they're just like if
something's coming near you that like
violin starts to swell like in every
creepy horror movie you've seen like oh
he's around the corner like don't go in
there basically and it gives you these
audio cues of like there somewhere so
you start to panic and you turn around
being like where is he like weird like
and he could be anywhere he'd be above
you be below you but that music gets
louder louder louder and doesn't go away
unless you move away or he moves away so
the game sort of pipes you up for that
scare and when they come up close to you
and get right in your face it's really
terrifying yeah and it's likewise when
you are the monster there's a lot of
really good sound effects these snarl
effects these rolling noises that make
you feel really vicious the screaming
when they die
oh it's just all kind of culminates
together into this like really
aggressive terrifying experience I
really enjoyed it and I'm so glad you
showed it to me yeah thank you for
coming to play with me it's really
awesome and it'll come out this year
they said they're aiming for this year
and they're going to start with pc so
it'll be on steam oh my gosh I think
this might be the best interactive
laxative I have seen GDC 2015 laxative
of the year the flock